The banking
crisis the US
is experiencing right now
has pushed us closer to a recession.
That is the headline
from JPMorgan Chase CEO Jamie Dimon,
who told us that
and a lot more in
his first extensive interview
since the collapse of Silicon
Valley bank and Signature Bank
last month.
We went down to Atlanta
to sit down with him,
where he was taking part
in a community center branch opening
in the historic district of Summerhill,
one mortgage
and one business, one account.
It gets sold.
The saver helps you get a job.
So one skills.
And we do a lot of work with community
around community colleges and skills and
and affordable housing.
And you can lift up society
This is
the community center branch here,
but you have a lot of them.
You opened the first one in Harlem
in New York City in 2019
you've got 16 cities now. Atlanta.
Why do you do this?
Yeah, this is a great idea.
Someone had was a mine
for the community branch
so it's bigger as a community space
it's built by local contractors
think of minority
contractors, local food,
local art artists
you know people put the art up when we
we hire locally
we have what we call community managers.
You have a branch manager traditional
for the community manager
get to know all the local businesses
not for profit religious institutions.
We invite people in
to learn about mortgages and saving money
and starting a business
and it's been unbelievable.
I've been like 14 of the 16 or so.
We've always taken the community manager.
We have 120 that's works so well.
We're putting them
in a lot of different communities.
So that's just
part of what we try to do that
when we enter a town,
we have 30% of our branches.
So in low income neighborhoods
and we just try to lift our neighborhoods
and bring in all the things
that JP Morgan Chase can do to help.
One of the things you say though,
because this is part of
the $30 billion commitment
to black and brown communities
across the country,
but you hear you explicitly
say this isn't charity.
Yeah, there's a strong business case.
Yeah, that's totally true.
And there's two things.
So those are huge numbers that we say.
12 billion of affordable housing.
8 billion in mortgages.
But at the end of the day
it takes place in a local a local place.
The mortgage loan officer know
reaching out to people,
helping them
through the programs,
getting them a homeowner's grant
if they need something like that.
So that's how it takes place.
But when you do it,
you know, we're right
across from Georgia State University
they're businesses
opening up around here, partially
because every branch in here
and a list up the community.
But it's also good business.
And you want good business
as these businesses come here they are
they're hiring locally,
their paychecks in the neighborhood
and a list of everybody.
So that's part of the job of a bank.
What's interesting,
though, about this
time, exactly this moment
that we're sitting down
is we're in a rising
interest rate environment
and it is harder
for folks to get mortgages.
You've lamented
that reality, especially for low,
lower
income individuals,
especially for lower income individuals
in this country right now.
Do you think
given the high prices of homes now,
the rising interest rate environment,
this American dream of owning
a home
is really no longer for a lot of folks.
I think we have to bring it back.
You know, if you look at homes
that are for most people,
the way you start building
family net worth and family wealth,
and there are a lot of things to do.
And sure,
you already see home
prices are down in some places.
Builders are already making concessions.
We do a lot of special things,
you know,
special purpose
credit for sometimes
in low income neighborhoods.
I think the government
can do a lot of things.
So, you know,
we talk about these things here,
but the government can do a lot of things
to reduce the cost they're doing now.
Absolutely.
What reducing
production costs,
servicing costs, origination
costs,
securitization costs,
which would make the cost
of a small mortgage,
but probably 50 to 75 basis points
cheaper than a loan.
A lot of money a month.
That's a lot of money a month
and make it available to more people.
So and we try to take policies,
you know, things we do here,
but also worry
about what
Washington can do to make it easier
to accomplish.
Listening to you,
I've been digging in this one
for a long time.
I'm praying, I'm begging.
I hope they'll listen to this.
It's so important.
And the other important thing is
we're not doing it for JPMorgan.
It won't affect the future.
JPMorgan, if we make mortgages
more available
to lower income folks around America,
it's so important
for lower income
America and so, you know,
we won't stop pushing
this one till we get it done.
I think we should double the
earned income tax credit.
And then there is Warren
Buffett has been saying that for years.
So if the American public,
if you if someone if a single parent is
with two kids
is making $14,000
a year,
the government gives you six roughly.
If you're don't have children
getting about $600.
My view is
we need to get more income
into neighborhoods.
So if you
if you kind of add to that earned income
tax credit,
I would get rid of the child
requirement requirement
or you get more money
into the neighborhoods
and that money will be well spent.
It will lift up those communities.
There'll be nothing like that.
And the other thing
I remember is job to bring dignity
jobs, bring better social outcomes,
you know, jobs,
that first job,
because sometimes people
make fun of the burger flipper job.
Very often that burger
flipper own ends up
owning the restaurant. Done it.
Exactly.
We've all done it
in that first job,
that first rung on the ladder.
Have you done it?
No, but I served in the restaurant.
Yes. I used to be a waitress.
We're
just getting people to open account.
We've got a counter
you could open here, start saving money,
thinking about it.
You know, a lot of us had the benefit.
Their mom
or dad took us to a branch
and we saw the first pass for that.
And then you see your money
go from like $84.75 to $85.17.
So, like, that was magic. There's a God
interest
and so
people learn,
and we want that to take place here.
You know,
we don't want people to be afraid
to walk into a branch here.
You come as you are, bring your kids,
you know,
learn what you're doing
and that's why
the community marriage is so important,
because a lot of people,
you know,
look at a bank
and they're going to walk by.
It's not what they're comfortable with.
And we want this community
very comfortable walking in here.
I just read your annual letter
that just came out this week.
And let's dove into the banking crisis,
because you write a lot about it.
Is the current banking crisis over I
this is not 2008, okay.
This is much more limited.
There are only a handful of banks
that have this particular problem.
They'll eventually be resolved
one way or another.
And I think
people should take a deep breath
in a week or two.
A lot of these banks
have been reporting earnings.
I think they're probably pretty good.
The Federal Reserve
made some
bold dramatic moves
to help it easier
for some of the issues they had.
And I'm hoping it will resolve,
you know, rather shortly.
You're hoping hoping.
But is the crisis over?
You wrote in your letter
there will be repercussions
for years to come.
Well, that's that's different.
I think
those repercussions are regulatory
like and,
you know,
acknowledged
think obviously we have a problem
and things need to change.
But you know, begging the regulars, let's
just take a deep breath.
There are hundreds of rules.
You know, you have to be very careful.
What do you want in the banking system?
What do you want out?
How do you make it easier for community
banks and regional banks?
How do you reduce their cost down,
increase their costs on it,
but also make it safe?
Do you expect more
banks to fail this year?
I don't know.
But if there are, I know
honestly, they'll be resolved in
probably the last of them.
I think
I think we're getting near
the end
of this particular crisis and fewer
finances to remember.
In 08,
it was hundreds of institutes
around the world, far too much leverage.
We don't have that huge problems
in mortgage markets. We don't have that.
This is nothing like that.
And the American public
shouldn't think that this will resolve.
And then we should go
look at what went wrong and fix it,
you know, in the clean
in the light of day.
Well, so then then what was it?
If this is coming to an end,
is this a situation like, you know,
Warren Buffett famously said
only when the tide goes out,
you learn
who's been swimming naked
or these banks swimming naked.
Yeah,
I said there's hiding in plain sight.
Everyone knew about insured deposits.
Everyone knew about insured exposure.
Everyone knew about held
to maturity portfolios.
The only difference
the only real difference was
we called concentrated clients.
So Silicon Valley Bank had,
you know,
a handful of people controlled
35,000 corporate accounts
and they just left,
you know, $140 billion or something.
Of course, of course of two days.
That's not happened.
All the regional banks,
they don't have that issue,
nor do they have all these other issues.
So it's only a handful much of sides.
But then
what's going on with First Republic?
I mean you led the effort
to swoop in $30 billion
from you and your fellow banks
to try to study first republic.
And you've acknowledged
we don't even know yet if that worked.
Yeah,
that was an attempt to try to resolve,
help, give them time
to resolve a situation.
We represent them.
So I really can't talk about any
more than that
and we hope it resolves
one way or another.
So that'll come in the future.
But I don't,
I don't think this is
that kind of crisis that
you're going to have it ongoing forever.
It will be.
Now, Warren Buffett said
when the tide goes out,
you mentioned some else rising rates.
Is that tide going out?
And if that tide goes out a lot,
so I would tell you
you'll be prepared for higher rates.
I don't know if that's going to happen,
but be prepared, you know, in that tide
you think the Fed raises again and may.
Well, there are two rates.
What is the short rate?
I do not know what they're going to do.
And obviously,
they may not be good for their,
you know, financial conditions,
but there's also longer rates.
And that has a different effect
and that the Fed does
not control directly
those controlled by global investors
sentiment, supply and demand.
And that's gone bad for sovereign debt.
Okay.
So, you know, to me, yes,
you have a chance along
rates will be going up
and people might get used to higher
for longer. Higher for longer. Yeah.
Get ready for that.
I believe that is a
I think it has a high outcome
to other people.
I'm not predicting it right now.
Is the American banking system truly safe
and secure? Yes.
I mean, the
banks have
extraordinary liquidity
extraordinary capital.
When they report earnings next quarter.
The earnings can be quite good,
in my opinion.
They can handle not just one stress test,
but multiple ways of being stressed,
the big guys who have to
abide by all those requirements.
I'm talking about the midsize
and little guys that don't anymore.
Well, they
they have far more requirements
than you think.
So I don't think it was the requirement.
If some people think that they were done,
that roll back
literally had nothing to do with it.
How do you know?
Because they had the same internal
liquidity requirements, stress
requirements,
reporting requirements,
supervisory requirements.
They made mistakes.
It was different
if they were under $250 billion in assets
not as much as you think.
So all those senators that are saying
it was wrong to roll them back, Democrats
rolled it back to some of them.
Those senators are wrong.
Yeah.
You know, look, it's not again,
you've got regulations
that's they're looking at one thing
and I'm looking at multiple others.
So they had high liquidity requirements,
high capital requirements,
they met the requirements,
they had too much industry exposure
and things should change,
but they were not out of line with super,
you know, with regulations.
It wasn't a regulatory change.
It was other things in life
that's going to happen.
This notion
that somehow you can make everything
perfect is wrong.
I know,
but you know, one
big well-known banks to collapse
no, you don't.
But you also really want
is that every now and then
something happened
and the system can handle it
in due course.
And that's what the. Yes.
Failure is. Okay.
You just don't want this domino effect.
And so when you have a bank run,
you end up
with some kind of a domino effect.
So, yes, my point is we we
we are close to it.
Get to the point where it can fail
and it doesn't have this kind of effect.
I think
just monitoring change in a few
things can get much, much closer to that.